great okay so um we're gonna switch to a
slightly different topic
um this is um a project that
uh i worked on with paige rodagero from
clemson university who's
also on the um in the audience today we
this summer uh ran a remote video game
coding camp for
autistic uh first years who were coming
into clemson
and i wanted to talk to you about how
that went and what we did to
accommodate the challenges uh that
autistic students face when they are
uh first engaged with college level
courses
so uh we built a coding camp this summer
um
and there were seven autistic college
first years who were part of
a clemson spectrum program
for new students to to the university
who are going to be rising
uh freshmen and our goals were pretty
much we wanted to teach programming we
wanted to teach communication skills
that were appropriate for working in
teams because that that's something
they're going to need for computer
science coursework
and in our particular case we wanted to
teach
video game design and
the results of our our our project
were uh to sort of emphasize how to
enable autistic students to feel less
anxious and less
stressed while working in teams which is
something that was relatively new for
them and in our course
uh we fortunately were fine able to find
that like
uh they learned a lot about
communication which was one of our major
goals
so let me explain uh what uh autism is
for those who are
uh new to this it's a neurological
condition it affects the way people
experience the world there are a lot of
differences that are
from non-autistic people or neurotypical
people
in social interaction verbal and
nonverbal communication
their range of interests might be very
constrained and there's
often repetitive behaviors now
it's not to say that all autistic people
are similar they're very different they
have a very wide range of abilities
characteristics and preferences
but these tend to be fairly noticeable
to neurotypical people
now in our coding camp the seven
students we have were self-disclosed
so they identified themselves and to be
part of this
particular spectrum program at clemson
we were working with thomas beeson who's
an aba therapist and also the
coordinator of the spectrum program
aba is applied behavioral analysis
therapy which is a very common therapy
for parents to
give to their kids who are diagnosed at
with autism at a young age
uh james uh dominic and connor phils
were our
essentially our student helpers um
tas if you will and we have basically a
summer course with three hours per day
on zoom we decided to use microsoft mate
code
which is a block based programming
language for building video games
and we went through maybe 13 or 14
different programming environments for
game
development before we settled on that
one so
like i said before the goals of the camp
are pretty much understand
game design and mechanics build a video
game with your team and then we had a
lot of very explicit communication goals
so learning to work in your team
which is really all about communicating
proactively and explaining what you're
doing to other people
collaboration reflection are kind of uh
also metacognition type of activities we
wanted them to
learn uh we wanted to help them get to
know one another and be able to learn
how to present work to others
especially strangers um so we spent one
week
uh the first week pretty much just doing
instruction and then a week and a half
with team projects um and when we did
the direct instruction because we were
doing things remotely
um we hadn't really ever seen a remote
camp
uh coding camp for autistic people so we
were kind of taking
ideas from other remote camps and from
other programming courses that were
given to autistic people
in person and so we adopted kind of like
an active learning approach to try to
keep people entertained uh for
or entertained or more likely to pay
attention
so there's like a c1 do one show one
type of model
where we would build parts of the game
pacman which was
surprisingly hard to build um and
uh we would do something then we'd have
them do something and then
we would ask one of them to show us what
they did and that was a cycle of about
like
three minutes each little chunk so every
10 minutes we did one of these cycles
we also did think pair share type
exercises to get them to
talk to each other and then
we did some paper prototyping for
planning um and everything we did with
them
we scaffold it very heavily i'll talk
about the scaffolding next
um and the students mostly worked with
their teams in breakout rooms and
we found that like many parents and
teachers are finding when they are
running zoom classes you kind of need
somebody paying attention to them
in the breakout rooms otherwise they
don't always do their work
so we always had an instructor for each
breakout room
and uh we tried to make sure that there
was structure
in their work uh something that's
challenging for a lot of um autistic
uh teens is to understand how to divide
their time
and uh so we had a scrum stand-up
meeting basically every 10 minutes that
we scaffold it
for them where you take a break reflect
on what you did and then switch
who's in charge of touching the computer
basically
one person could be coding and sharing
their screen at a time and then the
others would tell them what to do
and then uh after each camp day we would
meet all the instructors to discuss
each student and what their progress was
like and see if we had to make any
changes for the next day so it was very
very hands-on very
basically four and a half hours a day
for the instructor as well as about
three hours a day for the students
um now here's the things we did
specifically to try to
address autism um
so we emphasize communication skills but
we didn't just say
learn how to talk to somebody else
because that's not something that really
works um
when autistic people don't know what to
do they they can't figure it out
but we gave them scripts so we give them
a script to get to know one another
through an interview
we give them a script to figure out how
to talk to each other about team working
styles and process norms
and by not being capable it's like
nobody knows how to work together in a
group this is not a normal human
behavior that you figure out um it's
something that you can be taught
and if we teach them explicitly good uh
skills
they're going to take that with them
throughout the rest of their computer
science
uh curriculum uh we did the think fair
share and the c1 show one
we also help them structure work um so
the
part of the reason for sep for dividing
up the time
in their group projects into every 10
minutes was to
emphasize them to uh think about to
think about what they just did
and to think are we going in the right
direction should we change tasks should
we change direction
we also so try to enforce a regular
handoff
between the roles to teach them how to
switch tasks
and prioritize and plan and then
the final thing is each day because it
was kind of like about two hours of just
group work
we wanted to make sure that they would
end each day on a note on a high note
where they could actually have finished
something so the instructor would
pay attention in the last half hour to
figure out if there's a where the good
opportunities were to stop work each day
and suggest maybe after you finish task
x or
task y you'll this is a good place to
stop and you can pick it up
again tomorrow we also
had them work together in pairs and
trios
and that was actually super important in
order to get them to um
feel comfortable with people because
autistic people have trouble
uh tend to have trouble getting to know
new people and figuring out how they
behave
and what to say in response to what they
are into how they're being communicated
with
so the team stability here um
helps reduce the anxiety so what we did
is we made sure that they always worked
with the same pair in the same trio
every single day from the beginning of
the course actually
we asked them to um
learn how to or encourage them to
proactively talk about their work to
think aloud
which worked incredibly well with one of
our teams
so that the other person can keep up and
figure out what's happening and then
we had those standard meetings i said we
also scaffolded them too with scripts of
what you should say when you're in a
stand-up meeting
at the end of the course we had
presentations and we scaffolded the
presentation script and tell them what
to say
we gave them time to practice so they
could get used to the idea of what it's
like to talk in front of other people
but then talk in front of people that
they knew so they had practice in front
of their team
they had to practice in front of the
class and then they had to practice in
front of
visitors like their parents or teachers
who came to the class
and in in addition we also had them
practice individual components of the
course
of the presentation over the prior week
so they would get used to each piece
and so nothing was new on the day that
the highest anxiety would be there where
they have to talk to some new people
um in addition we also scaffold how to
say nice things about other people's
presentations and
how to receive criticism from other
people and what to say in response to it
and all those things are just things
that kids get taught
and it's very important to be able to
make them explicit for autistic students
to see it
so findings wise we have a couple quotes
which i thought were really nice
in communication we had one student
named luke who said
i forced myself to make time to let my
group members speak
and i made myself go against my better
nature which would be the talk
the entire time so that was all about
trade-offs um
handoffs between him and his partner in
another group
we had two women working really well in
sync but they left the
man out and he was not really paying
attention that much anyway
but whenever he was perked up and
decided to
display some kind of passion about a
piece of the project
um that led to a really great
brainstorming session where
everybody kind of came together um in
in the group and worked together now we
also noticed that
like adults often that i've seen in
microsoft
students have lots of trouble
recognizing when they're actually stuck
and they we thought the scrum method
would help them
promote reflection but only if they
wanted to
it turned out it was very difficult to
ask people to reflect
if they weren't necessarily inclined to
do so
now we did find that
one thing that we did helped a lot with
reducing stress which was we let
students
turn on or off their camera as they
wanted to and actually two of the
students were
did not turn on the camera at all
actually i think twice
accidentally they turned it on um but
what bob said was he honestly preferred
online courses because he can relax more
you're not staying at the desk watching
the instructor here you can just watch
from anywhere
um and it's something that that just
makes them
feel a little bit more at ease
especially when this was actually their
first experiences with online courses
because i think in the spring
their high school didn't really do much
with online courses the high schools
that they were at
um so we learned a lot about
communication
um and and specifically we kind of
really were focusing on self-efficacy
here so
um i'll just be almost done here um
so luke said i love the experience i
love expressing ideas
and so i especially enjoy just talking
about something where
with never having really done like
something like this before so that was
nice
bob um who is especially good at
expressing doing the think aloud um he
said i have
like all my head being able to work that
out and
make well i should have edited this for
uh teenager english
um i can work this all out
and pass on my knowledge to others and
get help and get everybody on the same
page which was especially important
because um
uh bob's partner was not talkative and
that's one of the
uh things we often see with boys with
autism is
sometimes they they just don't talk at
all or they talk very very
specifically about like when they're
asked a question now
martha was really interesting case
because she also didn't like to talk she
didn't want to have her camera on
but when she was in a group with her
partners she
would talk to them as long as the
instructor wasn't really watching
um but what she said at the end when we
asked like what did you really
get what value did you really get out of
this course she said well
people actually do want to hear my ideas
they do want to hear my input and
sometimes they do
think it's good and they do think it's
constructive and
that was super nice to hear because she
was the lea
she probably had the least
self-confidence of anyone in the group
and um it grew immensely just from
working with others
i thought that was awesome now
at the end here basically we're planning
to run this again
and again it's going to very likely be
remote
given covet we are going to recruit some
of the
previous camp students to act as
teaching assistants in the class
um in the next camp which would be kind
of fun we think there's probably two
who'd be really good
and we're also recruiting autistic
people to help us sort of fine-tune the
camp design
um initially this was created without
autistic input just from people who know
a lot about autism research and now
about working with autistic people but
i think it'll be even better with
autistic voices to help
kind of fine-tune the the particular um
tasks that we do and activities um and
maybe even the design
and then we're also thinking if we can
find other universities um and secondary
schools maybe in south carolina where
clemson is now
um might be a good way to expand the
program and address
more students which would be great
anyway so
thanks and i hope
we can do a lot for other students
coming into higher ed as well as k-12
thanks thanks andy i have
a follow-up question which may prompt
other follow-up questions
i wonder if you could say a little bit
about how
your work um translates into
things that happen um
beyond like sort of at a broader group
does it connect with other stakeholder
groups or
communities um are you getting any
inquiries from other
um i don't know similar researchers
do you see is there is there a bigger
picture that
is out there or is that still being
formulated i think that's still being
formulated
a lot of the work i've seen with
education for autistic uh um
students is certainly it's in person the
remote thing was very new
we didn't find anybody else doing that
yet we did talk to
a professor at georgia tech who's
going to start working with people with
intellectual disabilities in an online
course
uh we know of some work from cu boulder
of people working within
people with intellectual disabilities so
that's an in-person type of course so
computing courses for people with
disabilities are
a thing now it's not very common still
it's still like individual researchers
working
at individual workshops i haven't seen
anything
i personally haven't seen anything for
scale i think clayton lewis would be
a lot better to talk about those kinds
of efforts he's a lot more aware of that
than i am
okay great thanks um i don't think we
have any other questions so thank you
for uh jumping in and helping us with
this of course